[Musique]
Salut tout le monde. L'épisode que vous
allez suivre est l'épisode qui avait été
créé pour le magazine Pix and Love il y
a un an qui était sur le DVD. C'est
l'épisode de Captain Planet. Donc bon,
la plupart d'entre vous l'auront vu, je
pense légalement ou pas. Euh donc là, ça
fait un an maintenant on le met sur la
chaîne. Alors, concernant les épisodes
joueurs du grenier, là on est en
vacances jusqu'à fin juillet, mais on va
recommencer à les faire début août, ce
qui fait que le prochain épisode sera
fin août. Voilà, donc profitez bien de
cet épisode et ne vous demandez pas
pourquoi la caméra n'est pas exactement
la même. parce que c'est un épisode
qu'on a tourné il y a 1 an. Donc c'était
tourné avec euh une caméra un peu moins
bonne que celle qu'on a depuis quelques
quelques
[Musique]
épisodes. 1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
4 Ah, c'est l'été, il Il fait beau, il
fait chaud, c'est un temps parfait pour
se promener, pour voir du
[Musique]
monde. Vous savez, je suis pas un grand
fan des jeux de plateforme. Pourtant, il
y a un type de jeu qui m'insupporte
encore plus que les jeux de plateforme,
c'est les shoots mup. C'est même pour ça
d'ailleurs que j'en ai presque pas.
Pourtant, sur un des derniers salons, je
suis allé, quelqu'un m'a offert ce jeu
super Captain Planet et les Planet
Tears. Je te remercie à toi inconnu. Je
n'avais justement pas envie de vivre
vieux. Alors, Captain Planè, on se
souvient tous de cette
série. Le monde a
changé. Tout commença les cinq grands
anneaux furent
forgés. Un fut donné au Rukmou. dont les
taches de rousseur n'avaient d'égal que
leur absence
d'âme. Le second fut donné à la race des
blondasses. Terrible créature qui Hop
hop hop hop, ça va, on arrête là.
Donc, il s'agissait d'une série diffusée
à partir de 91 en France qui dégoulinait
d'une pseudoorale écologique.
[Musique]
Clairement, j'aimais pas du tout cette
série. Déjà, j'aimais pas le générique.
Les personnages étaient ultra clichés,
les aventures étaient totalement
inintéressantes et le héros Capitaine
Planè me donnait presque envie de
polluer juste pour le faire chier
tellement je pouvais pas supporter ces
moiral à de balles. Et évidemment pour
bien faire tourner la machine Afrique,
cette série a été adaptée en plusieurs
jeux vidéos et celui que je vais tester
aujourd'hui, c'est le plus connu,
Capitaine Planè sur NES. Ce jeu est
sorti en 90. Alors l'histoire du jeu, la
Terre est en danger et une vieille P
nomaya, non pas celle-là, celle-là,
voilà, décide d'envoyer cinq adolescents
venus des quatre coins du monde pour
risquer leur cul à sa place afin de
sauver la terre pendant qu'elle reste
sur son île à rien branlé.
Le jeu est composé de cinq niveaux,
chacun divisé en deux parties. Une phase
en shoot dans un vaisseau et une phase
où on contrôle Captain Planè. Il s'agit
donc sur ces parties d'un shoot meuble
classique où on dispose des quatre
pouvoirs des planétaires pour affronter
les vaisseaux ennemis à savoir donc le
feu qui tire des boules de feu en ligne
droite, l'eau pour faire des tirondulés,
la terre pour larguer des rochers et
l'air très pratique qui offre un
bouclier au
vaisseau. Et si j'ai dit quatre
pouvoirs, je ne me suis pas trompé parce
que exactement comme dans la série
animée, le mec qui a reçu la bague de
l'amour s'est aussi fait complètement
enflé dans le jeu. La bague de l'amour
sérieux. Et attention, pouvoir de
l'amour sur les vaisseaux. Yeah ! Je
t'aime. Je t'aime.
Voilà, l'amour c'est de la merde. C'est
dit. Alors au début quand j'ai commencé
à jouer à ce jeu, je me suis dit "Ouais
bon, OK sho du pauvre quoi." C'est
clairement pas très joli même pour une
Nesse, hein, mais bon, c'est pas très
difficile. Ça aura au moins l'avantage
de pas trop me saouler. Le seul truc
idiot, c'est que certains pouvoirs ne
servent à rien et il faut le savoir
comme l'eau par exemple qui ne peut
détruire aucun
vaisseau. Déjà premier problème, alors
ça peut sembler un détail quand on
connait pas mais c'est assez chiant en
fait, c'est que les boutons select et
start inversés. C'est-à-dire que le
bouton pour appuyer sur pause et sur
select et le bouton pour sélectionner
les armes est sur start. Alors, quand on
est habitué par défaut à changer d'arme
avec select, du coup, on narrête pas de
mettre la pause quand on veut pas ou de
changer d'arme quand on veut mettre la
pause. Le début du niveau 1 se déroule
assez facilement en fait. On galère pas,
c'est plutôt
tranquille. Plutôt
tranquille. Jusqu'à ce terrible
maman. Tu fais quoi là
? Tu quoi ? Je répè
l'ampoule. J'ai un appel. Allô ? C'est
réellement ici le premier passage
difficile du jeu. Vous devez passer ces
cinq machins qui tirent de l'huile là.
Et en fait, j'ai jamais réussi à le
passer proprement ce truc. Chaque fois
que j'ai réussi, c'était purement du
hasard. Heureusement, votre vaisseau
peut faire demi-tour, ce qui vous permet
de guetter
l'occasion. Enfin, s'il y en a une, moi,
je le vois pas perso. La seule ouverture
qu'il y a, ça dure une demie quand le
machin s'entour de l'écran. Ah merde
! Le souci du demi-tour, c'est que c'est
lent. Sérieux, le temps que ton vaisseau
il fasse demi-tour, la fenêtre de
passage a disparu depuis 5 ans. Mais
merde, sérieux. Et puis aussi, comment
en fait une flaque d'huile peut détruire
un avion ? Il a en quoi leur vaisseau en
pomme de terre ? Allez, mais non, j'y
arrive pas, j'y arrive pas. C'est c'est
pour ça que je déteste les shoots zup.
Ça ça me gonfle.
Bon ben maintenant si je veux pas que la
vidéo s'arrête ici au bout de 3 minutes
de jeu, ben je vais faire appel à mon
super pouvoir de montage vidéo.
Attention regarde. Allez vous avez
sélectionné une transition qui fait w
souriez. 3 2 1 wouch. Voilà donc après
avoir enfin réussi à passer ce passage
il y a quelque chose de génial aussi à
signaler dans le niveau 1. Quelque chose
que je ne savais pas les premières fois
que j'ai joué. quelque chose qui m'a
fait perdre environ 1 heure. Quand tu
arrives à la fin du niveau, après avoir
pété les tourelles, il faut se poser sur
ce machin vert là pour passer au niveau
suivant. Sinon, ce qui arrive, c'est que
tu t'écrases comme une mouche sur un
pare-brise sur le fond de la base et tu
as l'air idiot. Oui, c'est sûr, c'est
parfaitement logique de faire ça.
Surtout quand depuis le début du niveau,
le moindre fait de frôler n'importe
quelle surface suffisait à te faire
s'écraser. Bref, deuxième partie du
niveau 1 et là donc on entre dans la
partie du jeu où on contrôle Capitaine
Planè. Et comme pour le vaisseau,
Capitaine Planète peut utiliser les
pouvoirs des planétaires en se
transformant en boule de feu, boules de
terre, boule d'air, d'eau ou en cœur.
Sauf que tous ces pouvoirs, bah ils
servent à rien en fait hein.
Concrètement, il y a aucun ennemi réel
comme dans un jeu de plateforme
classique. On se contente juste
d'avancer bêtement en évitant de toucher
les murs qui sont recouverts de trucs
qui vous tuent en un coup. Les pouvoirs
quant à eux ne servent que pour
certaines situations ultra spécifiques.
Finalement, l'ennemi du jeu, c'est
plutôt la maniabilité de Captain Panet
qui est complètement savonneuse. Et
donc, reface de shoot Zup dans un
hélicoptère. Ce coup-ci, il faut
détruire des camions qui veulent déposer
des produits toxiques dans le parc de
Yellowstone. Et quoi ? Attends, les
arbres te tuent
maintenant. Mais pourquoi ? J'ai fait
tout le niveau 1 en passant devant des
arbres sans jamais que ça me touche et
d'un coup là, ils ont décidé que ça te
tuait maintenant. En plus, voilà
l'horreur et il suffit de
frô exploser Attention, attention. Ceci
est une alerte de blague déjà faite de
niveau 2. OK, ça va. Non, sérieusement,
il faut poser un caillou devant le
camion. Le camion ralentit seulement
quand tu es proche du sol. Sauf que
quand tu es proche du sol, après tu ne
peux plus éviter les arbres. Du coup, tu
es obligé de piler pour les éviter et
donc de remonter. Et là, tu perds du
temps et le camion a déjà
disparu. OK, j'ai explosé dans le
tunnel. D'accord, super. Ah non, mais oh
[ __ ] Bon, allez, je le rattrape, je
le rattrape, je le rattrape. Oui, oui,
oui. Non,
non. Allez, game
over. Oh, la planète meurt et ça me rend
toute triste. Ça va sinon ? Il fait beau
sur ton île, espèce de
[ __ ] Niveau suivant. Retour avec
Captaine Lavette. Et en fait quand vous
jouez à Captain Planet, abandonnez toute
notion de logique. La logique dans ce
jeu n'existe pas. Par exemple, à la fin
de ce niveau, juste avant le boss, vous
tombez sur quatre ennemis. Alors, voyons
comment tuer des ennemis avec mes
pouvoirs. Je peux les brûler, les noyer,
les écraser ou les souffler à mort. Et
la solution est le cœur. Et oui, pour
tuer les ennemis dans ce niveau, vous
devez les
[Musique]
aimer.
C'est Attends, attends, attendsendsends
attends. La bague de l'amour sert à
parler aux
animaux. Il y a pas la moindre logique.
C'est une division par zéro ce
truc. Et le boss, c'est pareil. Voyant,
il est entouré de petites boules rouges
qui ont l'air de dégager de
l'électricité. La logique voudrait donc
que je prenne la Terre, hein, puisque la
Terre ne conduit pas l'électricité. H
maintenant, ce raisonnement logique, il
suffit de le prendre, de le retourner et
de prendre le choix le moins logique
possible. L'eau ! Mais c'est bien sûr,
c'était évident. Non, mais comment
est-ce qu'ils ont construit leur jeu ?
Est-ce qu'ils ont tiré au hasard les
pouvoirs qu'il faut utiliser sur les
différents niveaux ?
Niveau suivant, un niveau sous-marin. Et
là, je crois qu'ils ont dû se donner
entre eux le défi. Genre, tu es pas
chiches de faire le niveau de shoot Zup
le plus mou du monde. C'est un nouveau
type de jeu, c'est un slow zup. En plus,
les ennemis mettent trois coups à mourir
et la seule arme utilisable, c'est le
rocher, c'est-à-dire l'arme la plus
lente du jeu. Alors bon, c'est vrai
qu'il y a une certaine logique à ce que
le feu ne soit pas utilisable sous
l'eau. Par contre, la logique qui fait
que l'eau n'est pas utilisable sous
l'eau, c'est enfin, je sais que j'ai
l'habitude de me noyer dans un verre
d'eau, mais là, on peut pas dire que ça
coule de source quand même.
Toute l'équipe joueur du grenier
s'excuse pour cette blague
particulièrement pourrie qui est tombé à
l'eau. Moi, s'il y a bien un truc qui
m'énerve dans les jeux, c'est
l'aléatoire. Et là, là, je suis servi.
Ces espèces de tourbillons, par exemple,
vous aspirent vers le haut ou vous
poussent vers le bas, mais il y a aucun
moyen de différencier les deux. Est-ce
qu'il faut que j'appuie sur le haut
parce qu'il va me pousser en bas ou
l'inverse ? Le seul moyen de savoir,
c'est de mourir sur chaque tourbillon et
de se souvenir à l'essai suivant. Mais
ça vous oblige à recommencer 10 fois le
niveau. Il y a aussi des grands moments
d'énigme comme ce passage où je suis
resté bloqué des dizaines de minutes à
me demander ce qu'il fallait faire.
Est-ce qu'il fallait attendre un passage
comme dans le premier niveau ? Non. Si
j'essaie de passer juste après qu'il ait
lâché son rocher.
Non. Et la solution est la piè visible
en bas de l'écran.
[Applaudissements]
Je vous l'avais dit que le niveau était
lentin. Et là, moment fantastique pour
finir avec classe. Vous vous souvenez du
premier niveau où pour finir, il fallait
se poser au sol, hein, parce que sinon
on allait s'écraser au fond du vaisseau.
Et ben là, changement de règle, c'est
l'inverse. Si vous vous posez, votre
vaisseau explose. Maintenant, il faut
foncer dans le mur pour finir le
niveau. Plus les niveaux avancent et
plus on se rend compte qu'on joue à un
pur try and die. Vous connaissez
forcément ce genre de jeu où vous êtes
obligé de crever au moins une fois dans
chaque piège pour les éviter. Et le plus
insupportable pour moi, c'est le niveau
de la neige. Tu avances tranquille, tu
meurs dans le premier piège, tu reviens,
tu évites le piège. Pavit de mettre plus
loin le second, tu reviens, tu évites
les deux et bim. Allez, tuer par un
ennemi de l'écran. Joyeux Noël.
Et ça continue jusqu'au moment où tu
arrives à The
Passage. Mais oui, vous connaissez les
Passages. Tous les jeux difficiles en
ont un le fameux passage qui te donne
envie de de mettre un coup de tête à ta
copine et de courir tout nu sur
l'autoroute. Comment passer ici ? C'est
[ __ ] de merde d'impossible.
La seule technique, c'est de faire un
demi-tour juste après que la neige soit
tombée. Ne pas le faire trop tôt, ni le
faire trop tard. Ça se joue au 10e de
seconde. Soyons clair, statistiquement,
vous avez plus de chance de voir un
quart de Norvégienne à poil s'arrêter
devant chez vous plutôt que de réussir à
passer ça. [ __ ]
! Oh oui ! Oh oui ! Oh [ __ ] ! Oui ! Ah
! Je suis un roi. Ah, je suis un dieu.
Ah, je
[Musique]
suis [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
F une
banane. Ah, je me casse.
Ben, tu vas où ? sur l'autoroute.
Bonjour, nous les Norvège nous cherchez
PL la ferme.
Par pure curiosité, je suis quand même
allé voir le dernier niveau en utilisant
le mot de passe et et c'est c'est
l'enfer
quoi. Euh je sais pas ce qui est le pire
hein. Est-ce que c'est le fait que le
niveau entier soit tapissé de ces boules
rouges qui vous tuent dès que vous les
touchez ? Le fait qu'on puisse pas faire
10 m sans crever trois fois ou alors le
fait qu'on affronte des ennemis
intouchables avec une box buggée et
d'autres qui vous tuent instantanément ?
À moins que ça soit la stratégie du boss
de fin aussi où il faut bouger toutes
ces pièces là pour lui renvoyer ses
propres coups. C'est vrai. Après tout
vous contrôlez un superhéros qui vole
qui a le pouvoir des éléments et une
super puissance pour déboîter n'importe
quoi avec sa force seule. Mais pourquoi
s'en servir ? C'est tellement plus fun
de faire des puzzles. Et toute cette
souffrance pourquoi au bout du compte
? Oh, c'est hyper pas mignon. Regardez,
c'est exactement le même écran que le
game
over. Allez, c'est bon. du
balai. Euh, ça me fait une raison de
plus de pas aimer le dessin animé. En
tout cas, un jeu comme ça, sa place
c'est à la
poubelle. Mais n'oubliez pas les
enfants, cette merde est un déchet
plastique. La poubelle
jaune car n'oubliez pas l'avenir dépend
de nous.
[Musique]
polard
la
pollu sera
trop la vie pollu polard je la pollution
polir sans te poser des Question.